hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen bei einer neuen episode von
kari antwortet also quick and oder zum
englisch just so bellino
das video ist gut aus abt audi aber kari
antwortete als war die yuuwaa come to
contribute to speak low level of german
is traum ist dass goethes native speaker
and feel you want you tube e mail viel
hat dann so dämlich das habt ihr als der
die hilfsmittel center e mail info at
the german doctors switchback to german
also ihr könnt die untertitel so
vielleicht in zwei oder drei tagen an
stellen wenn wir welche bekommen haben
das werden wir in den kommentaren posten
diese woche haben wir kein super easy
denn wie hier für euch gemacht denn wir
sind tatsächlich mal wieder unterwegs
und zwar sind wir diese woche in ghana
wo wir ein video drehen für eine
befreundete organisationen und in dieser
zeit haben wir viel zu tun aber wir
dachten wir machen zumindest ein kurzes
carey antwortet video denn wir haben
schon wieder viele fragen bekommen und
haben sie lange nicht beantwortet
unsere erste frage ist heute von der
gemeinde er schreibt carillo art
director uk news.at was the pearl index
wir haben viele kommentare bekommen zu
unserem video mit emanuel von your daily
german dot com
wir haben ja ein video gemacht über den
berliner dialekt und viele zuschauer
waren geschockt dass der berliner
dialekt so stark ist dass es überhaupt
ein berliner dialekt gibt und ja und
amen zum beispiel wie diese person hier
gefragt ob wir haben welchen dialekt wir
endlich sprechen wenn das nicht berliner
dialekt ist und was wir eigentlich in
den videos sehen wir sprechen ja jede
woche mit menschen in berlin
und ihr habt euch wahrscheinlich gefragt
welchen dialekt sprechen diese menschen
der berliner dialekt wird nicht so stark
gesprochen tatsächlich er wird mehr
außerhalb in den randbezirken von berlin
gesprochen und auch manchmal nur in
verschiedenen sozialen gruppen also
nicht jeder spricht ist es hängt ein
bisschen davon ab wo man aufgewachsen
ist ob die eltern einem das beigebracht
haben ob man das auf der arbeit spricht
oder nicht und ihr müsst euch keine
sorgen machen wenn ihr nach berlin kommt
werdet ihr fast alles verstehen denn in
der innenstadt spricht man eigentlich
immer hochdeutsch und berlin ist ja auch
eine mischung mit menschen aus ganz
deutschland also sprechen die meisten
hochdeutsch so wie übrigens auch in den
meisten anderen städten in deutschland
trotzdem in unseren videos hat man
manchmal den berliner dialekt müsst
immer darauf achten also vielleicht
jeder jede zwölfte bis 15 personen hat
einen leichten dialekt der mich immer so
ganz stark klingt aber wenn ihr darauf
achtet findet ihr den löhnen schreibt
carr ich möchte wissen ob du diesen
dialekt verstehst tatsächlich verstehe
ich den dialekt und der ist auch relativ
einfach zu verstehen im vergleich zu
anderen dialekten
es gibt die alex in deutschland vor
allem im süden von deutschland die in
dörfern gesprochen werden die ich
manchmal überhaupt nicht verstehe und
das passiert nicht so auf sie weil es
eben meistens in ländlichen regionen so
ist das dort und starker dialekt
gesprochen wird
in den großen städten wird eigentlich
fast überall hochdeutsch gesprochen und
auch ja sowieso überall hochdeutsch
verstanden also manchmal sind das dann
eher so ein paar worte oder so ein paar
ein paar unterschiede eine aussprache
die man schon hört in münchen oder in
stuttgart aber nicht alle sprechen dass
sie ganz stark
pure schreibt credit to work on a daily
basis mit standard germany zu lärmen du
solltest auf keinen fall
aber irgendwie alex lernen du weißt ja
noch vielleicht noch gar nicht wo du in
deutschland hinkommt standarddeutsch
oder hochdeutsch ist immer das womit ihr
anfangen sollst denn ein dialekt basiert
ja auch auf hochdeutsch also gesprochen
wird fast immer bei der arbeit in
hochdeutsch ist wird auch in den großen
städten überall hochdeutsch gesprochen
ist wird auch immer hochdeutsch
geschrieben also das was ihr in den
untertiteln gesehen habt im video mit
emanuel das wird nie so geschrieben auch
nicht fast nie in der chat sprache so
geschrieben also das haben wir mehr
ja diese phonetische trans transaktion
haben wir gemacht damit er das besser
nachvollziehen könnt und besser hören
besser verstehen könnt aber ansonsten
müsst ihr euch keine sorgen machen es
gibt in deutschland nicht ganz viele
starke dialekte und wenn werden sie eher
in kleinen dörfern in den kleinstädten
gesprochen und das könnt ihr dann immer
noch lernen wenn ihr da seid also da
werdet ihr euch schon dran gewöhnen wenn
ihr dann tatsächlich in einem bestimmten
dorf seit noch eine frage kommt von
larissa gandhara und da geht es um unser
video zum thema so proud to be german
sie fragt karriere bis du stolz
deutscher zu sein was eine sehr gute
frage ist und dieses ganze video how to
be german war ganz interessant weil das
war natürlich ein bisschen provokativ
gemacht es war auch ein bisschen klick
bate dahinter denn diese frage würde ich
jetzt mit meinen freunden mich unbedingt
diskutieren ich würde jetzt nicht fragen
diskutiert nicht mit mit irgendwie mit
meinen freund darüber auf wer stolz
darauf sein deutsch zu sein weil das
einfach für uns keine relevanz hat wir
können natürlich rose in deutschland zu
leben oder wir können uns besonders
typisch deutsch fühlen oder etwas
typisch deutsches nicht mögen oder etwas
in deutschland mögen und nicht mögen ich
mag sie sehr viele dinge in deutschland
wenn mich jemand fragt ob ich stolz bin
deutsch zu sein würde ich wahrscheinlich
sagen ja und nein denn
ich würde mich auf jeden fall als
deutsch identifizieren und umso mehr ich
reise übrigens immer wenn ich in afrika
bin in asien bin in amerika bin dann
fühle ich mich plötzlich sehr deutsch
weil dann erinnere ich mich plötzlich
daran was wir in deutschland alles
machen was so typisch deutsch ist woran
wir gewöhnt sind und so viele stereotype
stimmen wir auch das deutsche wert auf
pünktlichkeit legen das einmal alles
geordnet sein muss das ist auch so und
ich mag das auch insofern mag ich viele
sachen in deutschland ich mag dass wir
eine gewisse grundstruktur haben dass
viele sachen geregelt sind dass man
viele sachen direkt und ehrlich sagt und
darauf bin ich in gewissem sinne schon
stolz oder darauf freut darüber freue
ich mich schon aber genauso gut gibt es
sachen die ich eben scheiße finden in
deutschland und dazu gehört auch dass
viele leute keinen vernünftigen umgang
mit unserer vergangenheit haben
das ist zum beispiel eine sache die ich
nicht mag denn es gab auch unter diesem
video sehr sehr viele hässliche
kommentare die meisten davon habt ihr
wahrscheinlich nicht gesehen und wir
haben sie ziemlich schnell gelöscht
da waren beleidigungen beider waren
sachen weil die leute geschrieben haben
die einfach super hässlich waren und
auch das ist eben deutschland wir haben
jetzt zwölf prozent unserer bevölkerung
haben eine partei gewählt die
rassistische äußerungen macht ständig
und ich finde das einfach eine schande
und auch peinlich für deutschland dass
wir 80 jahre nach dem
nationalsozialismus jetzt wieder eine
partei im parlament haben die
rassistische sprüche macht und ja sowas
finde ich nicht gut und auch unter
unserem video haben wir sowas gelesen
wie wenn du nicht stolz auf deutschland
bist dann verpiss dich aus deutschland
und die frauen die gesagt haben dass sie
nicht patriotisch sind die will ich ins
gesicht schlagen und solche kommentare
standen unter unserem video und nicht
wenige sondern viele und daran sie
man eben auch dass viele leute in
deutschland nicht so einfach sich so wie
sie sind nicht so relax sind wenn es um
dieses thema geht und das finde ich doch
ziemlich krass und viele leute haben so
ein bisschen vorurteile dass die
deutschen mit ihrer vergangenheit nicht
richtig umgehen können oder dass die
vergangenheit sie davon abhält stolz zu
sein aber ich ja ich finde empfinde das
nicht so ich empfinde das nicht dass das
ein problem darstellt ich denke es ist
eher wenn es etwas ist dann ist es eher
eine bereicherung dass die heutigen
generationen davon etwas gelernt haben
denn diese ganze dieses ganze thema war
ja nicht 1945 vorbei sondern das ist ein
prozess der sehr lange gedauert hat die
generation von meinem opa meine oma die
haben den krieg miterlebt die waren im
krieg ob sie freiwillig oder
unfreiwillig im krieg waren sie haben
einen gewissen umgang gehabt und
meistens haben sie darüber geschwiegen
und haben darüber nicht gesprochen und
die generation von meinen eltern die
haben dann erst angefangen fragen zu
stellen in den 60 jahren in den
siebzigern haben sie ihre eltern gefragt
warum habt ihr das zugelassen was habt
ihr im krieg gemacht warum ist das
passiert
und erst 20 jahre später 30 jahre später
sind diese ganzen dinge aufgearbeitet
worden
und dieser prozess hält auch bis heute
noch an dass wir über gewisse dinge
nachdenken dass wir über gewisse dinge
mit gewissen dingen einen anderen umgang
haben und einen anderen zugang zu diesen
themen haben und ich finde das
eigentlich ja gut dass wir ein paar
sachen doch wenig reflektieren in den
aber auch genauso schade dass das eben
nicht alle tun und ich würde mir
eigentlich wünschen dass sich mehr leute
mit diesem prozess beschäftigt hätten in
deutschland wieso ist überhaupt dazu
gekommen ist und wie wir heute damit
umgehen
ja das waren heute ein paar gedanken und
einen verantworten an euch zu den fragen
die ihr gestellt habt ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen und ihr könnt mir immer
mehr kommentare schreiben mehr fragen
schreiben wenn ihr in eurem kommentar kw
also meinen namen rein schreibt und
finde ich die fragen schneller also
schreibt wo ich immer eine frage wie
kari was bedeutet dieses und dieses wort
dann nehme ich das in meine liste mit
auf ich kann nicht alles beantworten
aber ein paar sachen beantworte ich
immer gerne
danke fürs zuschauen und sonntag fällt
ihr das nächste video von uns das wird
dann wieder eine kleine überraschung von
einem anderen ort in der welt nicht aus
ghana auf jeden fall bis bald und schau